le nombre de travailleurs dans
l'industrie de la construction progresse
depuis 2015 assez lentement quand même
malgré tous les efforts fournis pour
augmenter leur présence sur les
chantiers avec nous ce soir Diagne le
mieux PDG de la Commission de la
construction du Québec bonsoir madame
Lemieux vous avez lancé un programme
d'accès à l'égalité des femmes dans
l'industrie c'était en 2015 à ce
moment-là il y avait à peine quoi 1% des
travailleuses dans la construction on en
est où aujourd'hui on est à trois points
c'est pas des révolutions mais en même
temps c'est majeur c'est très
significatif somme toute on a plus de
6800 femmes actuellement qui sont
accessibles sur les chantiers on a plus
de femmes companion on a plus
d'entreprises qui embauchent des femmes
mais c'est sûr que c'est un long chemin
on partait de loin la culture de
l'industrie aussi était pas
nécessairement très ouverte à ce
moment-là on est parti de comment
j'aurais dû d'un sentiment de
fait plaisir de résistance à une
industrie qui est beaucoup plus
mobilisée puis ça ça vaut cher cette
mobilisation là il y a des secteurs puis
on va le voir dans le tableau il y a des
secteurs quand même où il y a davantage
de femmes représentées les peintres par
exemple il y a des métiers on avait
d'ailleurs il a su des cibles pour
chacun des métiers il y a des métiers
qui ont rencontré leur cible et bien
au-delà il y en a d'autres qui ont
dépassé la cible qui avait été fixée il
y en a d'autres qui ne l'ont pas atteint
mais oui il y a des métiers on trouve
plus de femmes peintre
[Musique]
pâteuse
pour lequel il faut comprendre les
raisons pour pourquoi les femmes n'y
sont pas parce que techniquement on a de
plus en plus de technologie notamment
dans les appareils les femmes pourraient
y être alors ça il y a eu voir des gays
à faire dans certains métiers est-ce
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de résistance
de la part des employeurs mais on est
passé de à peu près 8% des employeurs
qui acceptaient d'embaucher des femmes
pour les déranger à 15%. ce qui est
quand même un gain amélioration
les entreprises embauchent une femme à
la fois alors il y a pas de masse
critique le gain par exemple plus récent
des dernières années c'est que les
employeurs quel que soit la taille de
l'entreprise sont partants pour
embaucher des femmes alors qu'avant
c'était plus ciblé mais oui il faut
convaincre des employeurs encore de
d'embaucher des femmes et dans un
contexte de pénurie on a un argument
très important cet argument là s'il
manque de travailleurs est-ce que les
employeurs sont ouverts à se tourner
vers les travailleurs ils n'ont plus le
choix ils sont beaucoup plus ouverts aux
travailleurs étrangers aux travailleurs
qui viennent d'un peu partout dans le
monde où travailleurs
issus de l'immigration Québec qui sont
au Québec et aux femmes ils n'ont pas le
choix parce que le bassin traditionnel
ou le jeune homme de 17 ans qu'on
repérait il est franchement épuisé
est-ce que les écoles qui forment les
apprentis les futurs apprentis les
futurs compagnons font des efforts
nécessaires pour attirer des femmes dans
le programme qui est pas le programme de
la Commission un programme de
l'industrie qui implique les ministères
et notamment les centres de formation
professionnelle il y a eu là aussi
toutes sortes d'ajustements parce qu'on
s'est rendu compte que au départ quand
on a fait le point sur cette situation
là que des femmes quittaient les bancs
d'école en cours de route alors on avait
des efforts pour les recruter mais elle
ne complétait pas donc ils ont dû faire
des ajustements dans l'enseignement dans
l'accompagnement dans le comportement du
groupe comment les jeunes hommes et les
femmes se côtoient dans une salle de
cours où dans un exercice quelconque
alors ils ont fait des ajustements mais
évidemment on a encore du progrès
d'ailleurs les femmes sont quand même
plus nombreuses à quitter le milieu de
la construction que les hommes une sur
cinq ne reste qu'un an vous dites quoi
c'est beaucoup en lien avec le climat de
travail puis ça c'est un défi pour
l'industrie l'industrie a une réputation
qui dure et elle doit trouver les
manières de manière de passer à autre
chose parce que ça devient rébarbatif
non seulement pour les femmes et
pour des jeunes aussi qui ont pas le
goût de travailler dans un contexte où
on règle les problèmes à coup de deux
par quatre il faut changer cette culture
là il y a des brins de vérité dans cette
culture là il y a des éléments vraiment
corrigés mais ça ça serait l'industrie
gagnerait au grand complet évidemment on
parle pas d'arriver à la parité là non
pas de ça bien sûr mais c'est quoi vos
objectifs quand même mais là on est en
train on a terminé le bilan on était en
train de travailler à une consultation
pour pouvoir repérer ce que bien
fonctionné dans cette première phase là
où encore on a des nœuds des écueils où
il faut faire des efforts particuliers
et on va se redonner une cible la cible
à l'époque était 3% en 2008
bon faut être patient mais c'était
réversible je sais que c'est un peu
homéopathique mais c'est irréversible on
peut pas revenir en arrière et là notre
défi ce sera d'identifier une cible
ambitieuse mais atteignable et tout de
même ambitieuse parce que c'est une
industrie où les gens gagnent bien leur
vie les métiers sont intéressants pour
les gens qui aiment ces métiers là les
femmes ont droit de gagner leur vie
aussi dans cette industrie madame lemy
vous êtes PDG depuis une dizaine
d'années depuis 2000 ans vous aimez
votre métier vous revenez pas en
politique non vous suivez la campagne
bien sûr ça vous manque ça veut dire que
ce qui me manque c'est non ça me manque
pas mais j'ai beaucoup d'intérêt
évidemment je lis entre les lignes il y
a des choses que je saisis parce que
j'ai déjà été à l'intérieur de ce de ces
organisations là et de ces moments c'est
quand même des moments uniques mais je
trouve que le climat est beaucoup plus
dur moi j'ai connu l'arrivée en
politique de la télévision en direct qui
changeait quand même la donne les
réseaux sociaux moi j'ai pas commission
politique et vraiment là c'est très
difficile puis les enjeux de sécurité
nos difficultés à voir un dialogue de
part et d'autre de la part des gens qui
s'opposent à des politiques ou des
aliments gouv bientôt il inverse ça je
trouve que socialement on a des petites
questions à se poser
merci merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]